what was like for you outside of Nas
you've done some big records with you've
done records with some [__] Legends
like what what what uh
is the record that almost happened
or that you thought Mike could still
happen in the future that you haven't
worked with somebody in terms of just
like an artist because I know we we had
discussed in the past you would almost
did something with Eminem back in the
day yeah but today that's crazy
um the probably the craziest almost
story was Nipsey
um
because I had just started working with
Scott I didn't have literally none of
these features yet right we just start
cooking up and my partners you know
that's from the Cannabis game he just
randomly brought up like you know I'm
mad cool and Nipsey and the team and
this is when Victory lat was everywhere
they've seen my favorite rapper like
especially then right that album like I
was like yo Nipsey to one and um
he's he called him right on the spot you
know what I'm saying and he's like you
know we work in this and this and that
let me introduce you to my guy you know
so briefly introduced us we started
slowly building that relationship never
met in person yet right and then he
connected me one of his team members I
send the record over and he hit me back
saying yo nip [__] with it you know
he's down to do it
um I'm like yo if it's possible I'm
trying to be in the studio all these
features except meth and French all the
others we're in the studio in the studio
together you know what I'm saying crazy
it's a different energy bro like I feel
like the Nas record would have been
wouldn't have been that if it was if you
guys weren't vibing with each other on
the hook together and [__] like that so
you know if I can which nowadays
obviously not easy especially for like a
big artist like that but anyway I asked
them and he's like yeah no problem imma
hit you you know top of the week and we
set it up
and that Sunday he got he got killed bro
damn yeah crazy crazy story
um so yeah rest in peace rest in peace
besides that yeah I've been around a lot
of people and it's like
um you know me and Ross talked about
doing something at one point
you know I learned like you can't take
too long when these opportunities come
take off we talk about this in the last
interview it was a brief combo with
takeoffs like yo send me something
because I offset and I had cuevo
um
I'm like yo you're the only me go out
and do a record yet you know what I mean
he's like yo what we doing send me
something you know and I lagged on it
you know what I'm saying but it's not
just because I lagged it's like I felt
like I didn't have the right record yet
because I hate having mediocre records I
see this all the time with a big name
for sure if you click on it like it's
cool that doesn't do nothing for you you
know I mean for your career it's a waste
of Smash If you have really something
undeniable and then you have a big name
on it it just helps then then you got
something you know what I'm saying uh
you have a this is a one-of-one jacket
you have on yes sir
thank you so when Jeff Hamilton when he
does so how much is this jacket
so basically uh this this Jack is kind
of a funny story Jeff Hamilton is my man
like I I got in a couple of jackets and
I got introduced to him to some mutual
friends and we became homies and then
one day I had a video shoot with be real
for a song called God flows
um and be real studio is literally maybe
a block or two away from Jeff Hamilton's
like showroom store or whatever so I hit
Jeff I'm like yo you think I can borrow
a jacket for the shoot he's like of
course come through so I go over there
and my boy found this one kind of
hanging in the corner it's like a
one-of-one custom you know I mean he's
like yeah I did that for a rapper
um I don't have to mention him but he's
like basically he ordered it but then he
never picked it up you know what I'm
saying ten thousand dollars but he's
like I don't care to me my jackets are
art you know I hang them up I don't give
discounts this and this and that so I'm
like cool he's like I take it for the
video I'm like perfect this is a perfect
Vibe for the b-real video this that I
went we shot the video on the way back
we go to drop it off my boys like the
whole time during the shoot my boy's
like yo this [__] is too fire like I
need that jacket you know but I didn't
think he was serious right we went back
to Jeff Hamilton and he he went up to
him he's like yo I need to cop that
jacket you know what's my price he's
like I really don't give discounts he
gave him like a thousand bucks off so he
paid nine thousand cash on the spot I'm
like bro and then he's like whatever you
wore in the video already so now
everybody's gonna think I borrowed your
jacket
so technically this is not my jacket but
everyone's gonna think it's my jacket
you know 9 000 jacket Jesus Christ yeah
Jeff Hamilton is a beast though bro
everything he does like every time I
wear a Jeff Hamilton jacket you get
compliments by everyone that well yo Sig
jacket you know what I mean for your
time bro